[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend noch zwei wochen bis
weihnachten und die infektionszahlen
sind weiterhin hoch wer sich in diesen
tagen an steckt ist bis einschließlich
heiligabend in häuslicher isolierung
nicht das was man sich zum fest wünscht
vorsichtig ausgedrückt und wie
weihnachten und silvester werden etwa
mit blick auf kontakt beschränkungen da
ist das letzte wort wohl auch noch nicht
gesprochen als erstes bundesland hat
niedersachsen vorsorglich eine
weihnachtsruhe angeordnet discos bleiben
zu für private zweig zusammenkünfte gibt
es zusätzliche auflagen stichwort impfen
bundestag und bundesrat haben heute das
geänderte infektionsschutzgesetz
verabschiedet und danach sind
beschäftigte im gesundheitswesen ab
mitte märz zur corona impfung
verpflichtet frank buchwald berichtet
lauter premieren diese woche in berlin
professor lauterbach etwa zum ersten mal
spricht der mediziner aus köln heute als
bundesgesundheitsminister und verordnete
dem land eine abgestufte corona therapie
wir müssen hier vorgehen auch die
mediziner hat sich der medizinische
befund verändert dann müssen auch die
therapeutischen maßnahmen entsprechend
angepasst werden ein weiteres mal hat
die ampel koalition heute das
infektionsschutzgesetz nachgeschärft der
lage angepasst sagt lauterbach das ei
nicht ehrenrührig die union sieht das
jedoch ganz anders jetzt davon zu
sprechen wenn die lage sich weiter
verschärft dann können wir im januar
nachschärfen ist eigentlich vor dem
hintergrund dieser entwicklung
fahrlässig wir brauchen jetzt die volle
handlungsfähigkeit des staates die ampel
contador stammen von den grünen etwa
auch er ein mediziner sie besingen
permanent ein altes gesetz was uns
überhaupt erst in diese vierte welle
geführt hat und nicht neue erforderliche
zielgerichtete maßnahmen wie es jetzt
braucht
schulschließungen oder ausgangssperren
gehöre nicht zu diesen maßnahmen
restaurants aber könnten geschlossen
messen und großveranstaltungen abgesagt
werden ärzte und pflegekräfte in
krankenhäusern oder altenheimen müssen
sich nun impfen lassen die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht gibt der gesamt
freiheitsplatz einen positiven effekt
nämlich den dass wir die gefährdung der
wohlhabend gruppen endlich in den griff
bekommen der afg geht jede impfpflicht
zu weit pflegekräfte könnten aufgeben
war die chef akzeptieren sie bitte dass
ich diese fachkundige bürger bewusst
gegen die impfung auch entscheiden
wollen das müssen wir anerkennen denn
mit zwang verlieren wir diese fachkräfte
für unser gesundheitssystem und damit
auch für die schwer erkrankten kritik
auch von der linken pflegekräfte hätten
jetzt vor allem mehr geld verdient
die neue bundesregierung bringt
innerhalb von vier tagen eine
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht auf
den weg kann sich aber nicht auf eine
prämie für pflegekräfte verständigen um
das deutlich zu machen ein grundrecht
relevanter eingriff im eilverfahren ist
möglich aber kein minimales dankeschön
für die pflegekräfte ist es peinlich bei
der abstimmung enthielt sich die linke
die union aber stimmt letztlich für
lauterbachs entwurf die neufassung sei
immerhin besser als das ursprüngliche
gesetz heißt es deshalb stimmen etwas
später auch die unionsregierten länder
im bundesrat zu viele der
ministerpräsidenten aber bleiben
skeptisch auch angesichts einer
drohenden home mikrowelle ich muss sagen
das was jetzt im instrumentenkasten
vereinbart ist das wird den ländern
gelegenheit geben zu reagieren auf den
besonders betroffenen ländern deswegen
geht es in die richtige richtung aber es
sind weiterhin
maßnahmen ausgeschlossen die in zweifel
vielleicht gebraucht werden insofern ist
dies nicht das letzte wort zwei wochen
noch bis weihnachten abermals wirft
corona einen schatten auf die festtage
und die politik hält den atem an
märz der neuen gesetzeslage gibt es
online auf zdf heute und dort finden sie
auch bereits das neue zdf politbarometer
dass wir in aller ausführlichkeit noch
am ende der sendung präsentieren unter
anderem mit fragen zur krone das
stimmungsbild ist da ziemlich eindeutig
zwei drittel der befragten plädieren für
eine allgemeine impfpflicht
die forschungsgruppe wahlen hat außerdem
danach gefragt wie viel vertrauen die
bevölkerung in das neue politische
führungspersonal setzt die einzelheiten
dazu wie gesagt am ende der sendung aber
eines schon vorweg für olaf scholz gibt
es vorschusslorbeeren
77 prozent glauben dass er seine sache
eher gut machen wird der neue kanzler
job führt scholz heute direkt ins
ausland nach paris und dann nach brüssel
an beiden stationen wurde er dabei von
unseren korrespondenten anne gellinek
und thomas walde beobachtet
olaf scholz trifft zu seinem ersten
amtsbesuch als kanzler im élysée ein und
soviel kann man vorweg nehmen und sein
gastgeber hatten sich offenbar
vorgenommen von anfang bis zum ende ein
bild der harmonie abzugeben wichtig ist
dass wir da gleichgerichtet agierende
djp.at ensemble ensemble zusammen
madonna gemeinsam aus sonne zusammen aus
sammler dass wir miteinander
zusammenarbeiten
miteinander zusammenarbeiten will man
bei allen wichtigen themen beispiel
einst die krise in der ukraine
natürlich gibt es eine gemeinsame
klarheit darüber dass die
unverletzlichkeit der grenzen in europa
zu den prinzipien gehört die alle in
europa für gemeinsame sicherheit
akzeptieren müssen ich unterschreibe
alles was der kanzler gesagt beispiel 2
will man die olympischen spiele in china
wie andere westliche länder diplomatisch
boykottieren sie ihre leser sondern bei
den olympischen spielen werden wir uns
mit unseren europäischen partnern
abstimmen dachte nach europa was die
entwicklung
der olympischen spiele betrifft ist es
in der tat so dass wir noch das gespräch
mit vielen anderen suchen beispiel 3 das
geld gestern stellte emanuel makro die
ziele der französischen eu
präsidentschaft vor er will dass europa
viel investiert und dafür auch reichlich
schulden macht ein widerspruch der
deutschen sparsamkeit geht ja darum dass
wir das wachstum das wir mit dem
wiederaufbau von auf den weg gebracht
haben auch weiterhin ermöglichen und
aufrecht erhalten und dass wir
gleichzeitig für solide finanzen sorgen
es ist möglich beides gleichzeitig zu
erreichen und keinen gegensatz das ist
das was uns soweit ich das dürfte ja
auch ein nicht mal bei den finanzen also
wollten scholz und makro heute ein blatt
zwischen sich lassen und sonst auch
nicht schließlich will man ja
miteinander zusammenarbeiten
nach pariser pracht und gold glanz kommt
olaf scholz in brüssel im schneeregen an
und in den mühen der europäischen ebene
eine schlappe deutsche fahne vom grauen
gebäude der eu kommission mehr prunk hat
europa nicht zu bieten drinnen trifft
der neue kanzler eine alte bekannte mit
der er immerhin anderthalb jahre im
kabinett merkel zusammen gearbeitet hat
für ein duo hat es allerdings nicht
gereicht
sie hier als deutscher bundeskanzler bei
der europäischen kommission begrüßen zu
dürfen die cdu politikerin jetzt
eu-kommissionspräsident in braucht die
ampel regierung von olaf scholz um ihre
klimapläne den sogenannten green deal
durchzusetzen sie hofft auf eine
vorreiterrolle des größten industrie
landes in der eu und scholz verspricht
naja fast
große bevölkerung eine große
wirtschaftskraft und deshalb kann die
deutsche politik nicht am rande und vom
rande hier kommentare zur europäischen
politik verschicken sondern sie muss
sich unmittelbar verantwortlich fühlen
für den fortschritt in europa es geht
ums klima um die schuldenregeln die die
südeuropäer und vielleicht auch
sozialdemokrat scholz ausweichen wollen
und immer wieder um die rolle der eu in
der welt ist dieses europa stark genug
um china in schach zu halten und
russland die stirn zu bieten
scholz wird immer wieder nach der
spaltenden gaspipeline nord stream
gefragt die eu kommission hat das
deutsch russische projekt immer für
falsch gehalten
laut kritisiert hat sie es nicht auch
heute nur so viel
wir uns ist wichtig aggressionen muss
ein preisschild haben allgemein gilt
dass
wichtig ist dass energie niemals als
druckmittel benutzt werden darf und dass
die energiesicherheit europas und seiner
nachbarn gewährleistet sein ist scholz
übergeht die frage nach nord stream und
brauchst weiter zur nato der russische
truppenaufmarsch an der grenze zur
ukraine ist bei jedem stopp seiner
antrittsreise ein thema natürlich sagt
scholz sei die souveränität der ukraine
nicht verhandelbar die ampel koalition
stehe zur nato auch wenn sie sich nicht
darauf einigen konnte 2 prozent der
wirtschaftsleistung für verteidigung
auszugeben
die verteidigungsausgaben deutschland
sind in einer weise gestiegen wie das
viele viele jahre nicht der fall war
dass es jetzt auch etwas was wir
fortsetzen werden im rahmen der
haushalts möglichkeiten die wir haben
und so klingt der neue deutsche kanzler
fast wie seine vorgängerin dass er
europa zu viel versprochen hätte kann
man ihm nicht vorwerfen
lieber nicht festlegen am zweiten tag im
amt im schneeregen von brüssel
auch außenministerin bernburg ist auf
dienstreise heute in polen es ist kein
leichtes pflaster und damit beginnt die
nachrichten heinz außenministerin
berbalk hat bei ihrem antrittsbesuch in
warschau die freundschaft beider länder
hervor gehoben in gesprächen mit
präsident duda und dem polnischen
außenminister betonte sie die
deutsch-polnische verbundenheit zeit für
die eu unbezahlbar bei den treffen habe
man aber auch eine strittige fragen
gesprochen polen steht beim thema
rechtsstaatlichkeit in der kritik
die kultusministerin und minister der
länder halten der korona krise an ihrer
linie fest schulen sollen offen bleiben
in einem beschluss der
kultusministerkonferenz heißt es der
kontinuierliche präsenzunterricht habe
weiterhin höchste priorität und das
recht der kinder und jugendlichen auf
bildung und teilhabe zu gewährleisten
auch an den hochschulen soll der präsenz
betrieb weiterlaufen
zu den aktuellen corona zahlen das
robert koch institut meldet 61
1288 neuinfektionen binnen eines tages
das sind 13.000 64 weniger als vor einer
woche
484 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incident sinkt auf 4
113,7
in hamburg ist den behörden nach ein
islamistische terror anschlag verhindert
worden bereits im august sein 21
jähriger verhaftet worden seitdem sitzt
er in untersuchungshaft
laut den sicherheitsbehörden soll der
verdächtige zudem kontakte in die
salafistische islamistische szene haben
in seiner wohnung seien bestandteile zum
bau eines sprengsatzes gefunden worden
erklärte die polizei außerdem habe er
versucht im tag net eine waffe zu kaufen
im süden mexikos sind bei einem schweren
lkw unfall mindestens 54 migranten ums
leben gekommen und mehr als 100 menschen
wurden verletzt nahe der grenze zu
guatemala hatte sich der lkw vermutlich
wegen überhöhter geschwindigkeit
überschlagen laderaum sollen sich eng
aneinander gedrängt bis zu 200 migranten
befunden haben die offenbar in die usa
gelangen wollten ein großteil von ihnen
soll aus guatemala stadt
die geschichte des julian assange spielt
ja auf zwei ebenen
da ist das individuelle schicksal mit
einer schillernden persönlichkeit unter
dem grossen flucht und isolations drama
mit den jahren in der londoner botschaft
von ecuador eine art freiheit in
gefangenschaft auf großer weltbühne
darüber liegt aber noch eine ganz andere
grundsätzliche ebene nicht nur für die
anhänger von assange auch für
journalisten und
menschenrechtsorganisationen weltweit
ist assange ein präzedenzfall für die
pressefreiheit geht es doch um die frage
was mit jenen geschieht die missstände
ans licht der öffentlichkeit bringen aus
sicht der us-regierung ist assange
hingegen ein spion und geheimnisverräter
um seine auslieferung wird seit jahren
juristisch gerungen heute gab es dazu in
london ein weiteres gerichtsurteile
darüber berichtet diana zimmermann
in den augen der anhänger von julian
assange ist das heute vor dem londoner
high court gefallene urteil eine schande
für viele beobachter ist es eine
überraschung das gericht entschied dass
der gründer von wikileaks doch in die
usa ausgeliefert werden dürfe gar nicht
erstaunt zeigt sich der rechtsexperte
nick will muss man zu anderen
gesundheitszustand mental wie physisch
ist ernst und hat sich in der haft
weiter verschlechtert deswegen wurde
seine auslieferung ja auch untersagt
aber die usa haben umfassende
zusicherungen über seine haftbedingungen
in den usa gemacht und unser gericht ist
der ansicht dass diese nun angemessen
auf seine gesundheit und sein selbstmord
risiko eingehen
das gericht beruft sich auf langjährige
beziehungen zu den usa die diplomatische
zu sagen dieser art noch nie gebrochen
hätten amnesty international und dagegen
hält die versprechungen für völlig
unzureichend
für julien assange der erst sieben jahre
in der botschaft ecuadors in london und
nun schon seit zweieinhalb jahren im
hochsicherheitsgefängnis von werma
schwitzt ist die entscheidung ein harter
rückschlag
so wie auch für stella maris partnerin
und mutter zweier seiner kinder die
direkt nach der entscheidung ankündigte
in berufung zu gehen
wir werden kämpfen jede generation hat
ihren kampf und dieser der unsere denn
syrien repräsentiert die fundamente
dessen was es bedeutet in einer freien
gesellschaft zu leben und pressefreiheit
zu haben das königreich sperrt
journalisten ein
natürlich ist das haus nicht irgendein
journalist ihm wird spionage vorgeworfen
enthüllung von staatsgeheimnissen
theoretisch drohen ihm bis zu 175 jahre
gefängnis in den usa die nun großzügig
anbieten er dürfe seine haft auch in
australien absitzen den von assange
anhängern immer wieder geäußerte vorwurf
auch die englische justiz sah in diesem
fall politischem druck ausgesetzt weiß
der experte für auslieferungsrecht
zurück
heraus dass politiker einfluss nehmen
auf juristische entscheidungen oder dass
ein politiker ein stilles wort mit einem
richter gewechselt hat dann müsste er
sofort zurücktreten
es wäre ein empörender verstoß gegen die
gewaltenteilung und ich bin froh sagen
zu können dass es dafür in der
geschichte des königreichs kein fast
kein beispiel gibt
wenn es geht davon aus dass assange am
ende ausgeliefert werden wird von einer
unabhängigen englischen von eine
unabhängige amerikanische justiz
verteidiger und anhänger assange sehen
das naturgemäß anders sie halten das
verfahren für einen abgekarteten
schauprozess und wollen weiter dafür
streiten dass ihr held freikommt
es gehört zur ironie der geschichte dass
der zweite weltberühmte whistleblower
der sich mit den usa anlegte etwas
snowden ausgerechnet in moskau asyl
gefunden hat geduldet und
propagandistisch benutzt von einem
regime das mit pressefreiheit nun
wirklich gar nichts am hut hat und dafür
sorgt dass kritiker oder gar
geheimnisverräter im eigenen land
mundtot gemacht werden nicht selten im
wahrsten sinne des wortes das wurde auch
heute noch mal deutlich als der
russische journalist dimitrij muratow
auf den friedensnobelpreis entgegen nahm
erteilt in sich mit der philippinischen
kollegin maria riesch zwei mutige die
wissen was es bedeutet für
pressefreiheit kämpfen zu müssen von der
verleihung in oslo berichtet heike kruse
dass sie heute persönlich nach oslo
kommen konnten war lange nicht sicher
denn maria resser stammt von den
philippinen
ihr kollege dimitrij muratow aus
russland zwei autoritär regierten
staaten und beide journalisten bekamen
den friedensnobelpreis wegen ihres
einsatzes für die meinungsfreiheit in
ihren heimatländern dagegen gestimmt
dass der preis heute an journalisten
geht ist ein signal ein historischer
moment für das nobelpreiskomitee
journalismus ein grundpfeiler der
demokratie
maria reiser war journalistin in den usa
ging von neun jahren zurück in ihrer
heimat auf die philippinen sie wurde
dort mitbegründerin des online
nachrichtenportals keppler das
kritisiert immer wieder den mörderischen
anti drogen krieg von staatchef du
tertre maria weiss team im interview
schwerste menschenrechtsverletzungen
nach sie wird wegen ihrer arbeit
behindert verfolgt wird mehrfach
verhaftet und verklagt sie ist furchtlos
und energisch
journalismus ist kein verbrechen dem
wurde der russe dimitri muratow auch
sicher sofort zustimmen er ist
chefredakteur der zeitung nowaja gaseta
der letzten unabhängigen zeitung in
russland seit jahrzehnten berichten
dimitrij muratow und die ganze redaktion
über korruption polizeigewalt
willkürliche verhaftungen wahlbetrug
kurz über das system putin
trotz ermordeter kollegen und ständiger
bedrohungen dimitrij muratow weigert
sich mit dem kampf für meinungsfreiheit
aufzuhören
journalismus macht in russland harte
zeiten durch in den vergangenen monaten
wurden hunderte journalisten
menschenrechtsaktivisten und
nichtregierungsorganisationen als
agenten fremder mächte bezeichnet in
russland bedeutet dass nur eins
volksfeinde
heute in oslo hat dimitrij muratow auf
einen wunsch eine schweigeminute
die body lasst uns damit unseren
kollegen zur seite stehen die verfolgung
erleiden ich möchte dass journalisten
alt sterben
maria reeser beendet ihre rede in oslo
mit einem aufruf gegen hass und gewalt
nicht nur im internet sie bleibt
energisch und furchtlos
wie jeden tag lebe ich mit der realen
bedrohung den rest meines lebens im
gefängnis zu verbringen weil ich eine
journalistin bin wenn ich jetzt nach
hause fahre weiß ich nicht wie die
zukunft wird aber es ist das risiko wert
dies wollte riss
maria resse und mitri murat auf teilen
sich das preisgeld von mehr als 900
80.000 euro damit wollen sie ihren kampf
für die meinungsfreiheit weiter führen
und
jetzt macht noch mal 112 weiter mit
wirtschaft an der frankfurter börse gab
es heute ein debüt daimler truck ist
dort gestartet das von daimler
abgespaltene lastwagen und busgeschäft
frank wittmann zuerst die frage warum
überhaupt diese aufspaltung die idee
dahinter die einzelnen teile sind mehr
wert als das ganze etwas was wir hier in
der vergangenheit immer wieder erlebt
haben bei siemens oder bayer die
ebenfalls töchter unternehmen an die
börse brachte anderszewski länder es am
morgen beim börsenstart die abspaltung
sollte das volle potenzial beider
unternehmen frei setzen und
entscheidenden mehrwert schaffen hier an
der börse hat das heute schon mal
funktioniert die daimler aktie verliert
durch die abspaltung zwar knapp 12 euro
dafür die neue daimler truck aktie auf
anhieb mit fast 30 euro bewertet für
jeweils zwei daimler papiere bekommt man
eine zusätzliche daimler truck aktie für
die aktionäre zunächst ein gutes
geschäft und warum gerade jetzt dieser
schritt mehr eigentlich hätte man das
schon viel früher machen müssen den
synergien zwischen pkw und lkw geschäft
gab es nie wirklich stattdessen stehen
beide staaten auch die trucks vor einem
gewaltigen wandel hin zur
elektromobilität als eigenständiges
unternehmen so die hoffnung bekommt die
nutzfahrzeugsparte dass künftig besser
hin
rieseninvestitionen stehen da an vor
allem in brennstoffzellen antriebe auch
für den nach eigener aussage weltgrößten
lkw hersteller nicht leicht zu stemmen
frank wittmann vielen dank
das statistische bundesamt hat seine
erste schätzung zu einem weiteren
preisschub im november bestätigt
angeheizt insbesondere von gestiegenen
energiepreisen gab es gegenüber dem
vorjahresmonat einen anstieg um 5,2
prozent und auch aus den usa kamen heute
neue zahlen zur inflation dort stiegen
die verbraucherpreise im jahresvergleich
im november um 6,8 prozent das ist die
höchste inflationsrate seit dem jahr
zum ersten mal seit acht jahren haben
die deutschen handballerinnen eine wm
viertelfinale erreicht die dhb auswahl
von bundestrainer henk groener gewann
gegen asienmeister südkorea mit 37 zu 28
und sicherte sich einen der beiden
ersten gruppenplätze beste werferinnen
waren die kapitänin im werk und alina
grätzels mit je acht treffern machten
sie den fünften sieg im fünften spiel
perfekt
der norweger magnus carlsen hat seinen
weltmeistertitel im schach verteidigt in
dubai besiegte der 31-jährige seinen
russischen herausforderer
janikowski nach dem elften von maximal
14 partie außerdem durfte sich carlsen
über ein preisgeld von 1,2 millionen
euro freuen carlsen ist seit acht jahren
weltmeistern
überraschungssieger des zehn kilometer
biathlon sprint in hochfilzen wurde
heute johannes kühn für den 30 jährigen
der bislang erfolgreichste tag im
weltcup
mit einer phänomenalen schlussrunde
holte johannes kühn den ersten
weltcupsieg seiner karriere nach zehn
kilometer sprint in hochfilzen steht der
30-jährige mit nur einem fehlschuss und
einer strafrunde überraschend ganz oben
auf dem podest mit mehr als 14 sekunden
rückstand und ebenfalls einem fehlschuss
wird martin pansy lohmar aus schweden
zweiter fehlerfrei aber deutlich
langsamer war anton smolski aus belarus
bereits beim weltcup in östersund hatte
johannes kühn die olympia-norm geknackt
ein perfekter start in den winter und
[Musik]
damit kommen wir zum ersten zdf
politbarometer seit dem
regierungswechsel
welche erwartungen richten sich an die
ampel und wie kommen die neuen köpfe an
alle fragen und ergebnisse präsentierten
jetzt matthias fornoff
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer
deutschland hat eine neue regierung die
erste bundes ampel steht spd grüne und
fdp haben sich über inhaltliche
differenzen hinweg geeinigt nach
aufgaben müssen kanzler scholz und seine
ministerinnen und minister nicht lange
suchen die sich ja drängendste wird sein
die korona pandemie besser in den griff
zu kriegen
doch deutschland soll auch umgebaut
werden vorreiter werden beim klimaschutz
digital modern zukunftsweisend und um
all das umzusetzen braucht es einen
fähigen kanzler
77 prozent der deutschen sagen scholz
wird seine sache eher gut machen 14
prozent meinen eher schlecht selbst die
anhänger der oppositionsparteien von
union und linke sind da mehrheitlich
zuversichtlich
nur die afg anhänger sehen dass
überwiegend anders
schauen wir auf die besetzung einiger
schlüsselministerien in corona zeiten
steht der gesundheitsminister naturgemäß
besonders im fokus doch auch der
finanzminister wird das selbst gesteckte
ziel erreichen müssen corona bedingte
mehrausgaben zu stemmen und ab 2023 die
schuldenbremse wieder einzuhalten auch
auf die neue außenministerin warten
dringende herausforderungen
dass karl lauterbach seinen job als
gesundheitsminister er gut machen wird
glauben 78 prozent der befragten 68
prozent erwarten dass auch von christian
lindner als finanzminister bei
außenministerin annalena baerbock
dagegen überwiegt mehrheitlich die
skepsis
kommen wir zu den zehn wichtigsten
politikerinnen und politikern im land da
zeigt sich großes vorweihnachtliches
wohlwollen alle steigen in der gunst der
deutschen nicht zuletzt der harmonische
regierungswechsel scheint gefallen zu
haben auf der skala von plus fünf bis
minus fünf belegte jens spahn mit minus
0,7 den zehnten platz davor sahra
wagenknecht 0,0 dann friedrich merz 0,1
annalena baerbock 0,2 platz sechs für
markus söder 0,6 christian lindner 1,0
lars klingbeil 1,3 auf platz drei robert
habeck 1,4 platz zwei für olaf scholz
2,1 und an der spitze noch mal mit
starken zugewinnen zum abschied angela
merkel 2,7
von den köpfen zu den parteien in der
projektion gibt es leichte bewegung wenn
am nächsten sonntag wirklich
bundestagswahl wäre dann käme die spd
unverändert auf 28 prozent cdu/csu bei
21 prozent plus zwei die grünen bei 17
prozent die fdp bei 12 die afg bei 10%
beide minus 1 die linke bliebe bei 5
prozent
das mit großem abstand wichtigste thema
für die deutschen ist weiter die korona
krise die fallzahlen sind hoch die
intensivstationen vielerorts stark
belastet die politik hat reagiert und
die maßnahmen wieder verschärft
impfpflicht etwa für pflegekräfte 3g am
arbeitsplatz kontakt beschränkungen für
ungeimpfte
35 prozent sind überzeugt durch diese
maßnahmen kann die vierte welle
gebrochen werden die deutliche mehrheit
von 61 prozent meint aber das klappt so
nicht die befragten sehen also weiter
handlungsbedarf 42 prozent sagen die
anti corona maßnahmen müssten noch
härter ausfallen und mehr als zwei
drittel sprechen sich für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht aus
die besonders starken einschränkungen
für ungeimpfte finden 77 prozent richtig
21 prozent falsch dafür gibt es sehr
große bis große zustimmung in allen
politischen lagern
außer bei den anhängern der afd
2021 ist das zweite jahr das geprägt ist
durch die korona krise es gab die große
hoffnung dass dieser winter besser
werden würde als der letzte es kam
anders so ist die stimmung der deutschen
im vergleich zur vor corinna zeit auch
deutlich gedämpft aber immer noch
mehrheitlich positiv und etwas besser
als im vorjahr
59 prozent sagen
2021 war für mich ein gutes jahr 37
prozent finden es war schlecht für sie
dass das kommende jahr besser wird
glauben 35 prozent der befragten 58
prozent meinen dass sich da nicht viel
ändert und nur fünf prozent befürchten
2022 wird schlechter
hoffen wir also dass die optimisten
recht behalten und das neue jahr in
sachen corona und überhaupt besser wird
als das alte
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute- app und oft zdf
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen informationen zur
methodik und zu den qualitätsstandards
finden sie unter politbarometer punkt
zdf.de
vielen dank für ihr interesse wer von
politbarometer verabschieden uns für
dieses jahr wünschen ihnen eine schöne
vorweihnachtszeit ein frohes fest und
schon mal einen guten rutsch
hier geht's nach dem wetter weiter mit
der heute show und oliver becker ihnen
noch einen entspannten abend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter diese karte zeigt
den durchschnitt der vergangenen zwölf
monate an und immer wenn ein monat dazu
kommt dann werden wieder die vergangenen
zwölf monate betrachtet und so hat man
ein zeitraum den man gut mit der
vorindustriellen zeit vergleichen kann
ja und dieser vergleich bringt dann
einen wert von
1,15 grad weltweite temperaturabweichung
eben zur vorindustriellen zeit wir
schauen auf das wetter und da bekommen
wir aus dem westen warme luft und die
erreicht uns dann zum sonntag vorher
muss aber der schnee hier noch
verschwinden bevor die wärme sich dann
ausbreiten kann ja und in der nacht gibt
es keine spur von wärme im süden ist es
dicht bewölkt mit schnee und teils regen
und glätte nach norden lockert es auf
und teilweise bildet sich nebel bei
tiefsten temperaturen von minus 7 grad
im osten deutschlands über schnee teils
darunter frostfrei ist es im südwesten
bei plus zwei grad morgen verschwindet
allmählich der schnee im süden
deutschlands in der mitte gibt es ein
bisschen sonnenschein nach norden hin
ist es dicht bewölkt und die
temperaturen erreichen höchstwerte von
minus ein grad im osten deutschlands
dauerfrost ihr plus sieben grad im
westen ja und am sonntag kommt mit der
wärme allerdings auch gefrierender regen
auf und das gerade hier im osten mit dem
gefühl mit den eisigen boden kann zu
rutschigen straßen führen 0 bis 10 grad
die höchsten werte am sonntag und der
montag ist ein wenig milder damit ein
schöner abend